the best actors often infuse their
characters with facets of their own
personalities sure that can lead to
better performances overall but it can
also lead to emotionally draining scenes
and in some cases identity crisis is for
actors who dove a little too deep into
their characters Jake I don't know who I
am anymore the get-down might have
fallen victim to its own massive budget
and co-creator Baz Luhrmann's busy
schedule but the show's betrayal of the
birth of hip-hop and its depiction of a
mythical New York City was a delight
while it lasted the show's intense
commitment to world building was also
reflected in the actors who practiced
choreography on set in a reconstructed
Queens neighborhood and even involves
some of the actors wearing
period-appropriate
underwear here you can go to if you need
to not know if I'm around money to be
one that don't retire just cuz Maas make
a restaurant with the wheel cheese and
the chilly ground me a seriously at
Ezekiel Brown actor justice Smith
committed to the role with gusto for the
long hours of filming unfortunately that
dedication to craft ended up taking an
emotional toll on the young actor when
his method acting techniques started to
erase the distinction between himself
and the character he was playing Smith
told vulture the lines get blurred and
you're like what is me and what is the
character and I really like this or is
that just him my biggest fear was what
if I don't come back what if I don't
return to Who I am in season 3 of AMC's
dark drama Breaking Bad Walter White's
DEA brother-in-law Hank is nearly shot
to death and he winds up crippled for
part of the next season
the character's former upbeat attitude
macho dialogue is replaced with sullen
blares moody silences and a frankly
stank outlook I leave this hospital when
I walk out of here understand and not
before
this continues episode after episode oh
and at mineral collection God that
mineral collection actor Dean Norris
found himself increasingly enveloped in
the newly grim outlook of his character
which necessitated weeks of filming for
the Ark according to Entertainment
Weekly Norris admitted you were
constantly dark for 15 hour days being
just depressed as a character and being
mean to my on-screen wife
I was just constantly in this kind of
pissed-off mood the whole season for for
me was not pleasant
still nor is his dedication to his craft
paid off in the long run after all if
Hank never took time off to recover from
his injuries we wouldn't have comedic
gems like this the rocks
hey Jesus Murray I got some jeans coming
that are very delicate all right well
orange is the new black might have its
comedic moments it also never shied away
from the deeply unpleasant realities of
imprisonment and sexism following a
group of women imprisoned in a women's
Correctional Facility the show features
the various intersections between race
class gender and sexuality in season
three a few finds Sophia a trans woman
sent to solitary confinement ostensibly
for her own protection after a violent
attack
Jesus bush said why do you have to make
everything so hard no offense
actress Laverne Cox herself transgender
admitted that although the storyline was
important to showcase it was deeply
upsetting to film
she told vulture when I read this
episode I was just in tears
I bawled reading it because it was
deeply triggering for me as trans people
of color there's so many different
layers of that so the trauma of that was
just very real and raw for me there are
plenty of loathsome villains in the
history of television
but very few have been quite as young
and quite as twisted as King Joffrey on
Game of Thrones even among the cast full
of violent monsters the young King stood
out as a truly sadistic character I
won't hurt him
much actor Jack Gleeson seems to be as
kind-hearted as his character is not
since he's gone on record as feeling
very conflicted over the violent acts
committed in the show as Gleeson said in
an interview with Rolling Stone you tend
to abstract yourself from the creepiness
of it when you're playing it but when
you see it on television it sends
shivers down my spine I would like to
try and defend him but I would have a
pretty hard job doing it Gleason even
retired from acting after his time on
the show ended and while we're sad to
see the young and promising actor fade
from the field we never get tired of
watching his character's retirement
while Kristen Ritter's got a bit of a
knack for playing self-destructive
characters like Chloe on don't trust the
B in apartment 23 or Jane and Breaking
Bad her performance in Marvel's Jessica
Jones is arguably one of her best the
show follows the titular super-powered
private detective as she struggles with
trauma in a world of unbreakable men and
manipulative monsters playing a
character that deals with such dark
experiences required Ritter to really
invest herself in Jessica Jones's
loneliness which involved a difficult
transition ritter told the Los Angeles
Times it definitely takes a toll because
I'm more bubbly and alive and zestful
and I like to have a good time so after
a while you're like oh my god I'm
getting really depressed and it just had
to move across the country so I'm in an
apartment that doesn't have my furniture
I'm not around my friends spend a lot of
time walking around doing the scenes by
myself in my apartment yeah that sounds
like a real bummer
but hey if Ritter's self-imposed
isolation led to her performance as the
ever badass Jessica Jones then it may
have all been worth it in the end
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]